et maintenant quatre boucles depuis
on a géré
ts de pierre
le premier
trois centres les siens
rejetant le vieux qui marin
je suis hors à madrid
bonsoir mohammed vi ça va très bien vous
connaissez guy a lepage
j'ai fait sa connaissance un climat qui
va en fait vous recevoir quand vous irez
au canada dans le tout le monde en parle
québécois commandes innovantes
humainement parlant québec - on parle à
lepage tu vas payer cela au milieu mais
personnellement il m'a dit alors c'est
pour ardisson mais bon je peux pas le
croire si c'est vrai nom s'est pour une
raison encore picone que ça c'est merci
pour thierry guy belux ensemble et le
fait que quand on est un artiste au
québec il faut s'inscrire à l'union des
artistes et il y avait déjà un guilty of
use
dans et l'imitateur andré philippe
gagnon peut-être que vous connaissez il
s'appelle pas du tout en gris philippe
s'appelle andré gagnon 1 et il y avait
le pianiste qui s'appelle andré gagné
par céline sable céline piot
ce n'est pas près d'aller au québec je
dis bien alors nous a maîtrisé vous
publié chez michel lafon un livre qui
s'appelle moment le turbulent sous-titré
de la voyoucratie à la jet set alors
c'était en 1968 et dans une rue
populeuse de tunis mais vous dites en
parlant de cette rue c'est ce qu'il ya
derrière les cartes postales les endroit
maudit où les tours opérators n'emmène
pas les touristes tout à fait même socra
vrai c'est le barbès montfermeil réunis
en même temps à 4000 en plus un
il ya dans 1 30 mètre carré ou 40 mètres
carrés il ya toute une famille c'est à
dire la mère le père les enfants les
beaux-frères et belles-soeurs le machin
et tout le monde vit là dedans même
temps quoi un cercle soir quand on quand
ils dorment ils savent pas où ils vont
dormir si c'est à côté de la cuisine à
côté des toilettes de la salle de bains
ya pas de règles il n'y a pas d'endroit
bien précis en même temps tout est dans
la même pièce effet qu'est ce que tu as
fait moi aussi ça t'énerve non c'est pas
taper jeu et afficher et m'a lancé un
petit défi
chez chez ruquier il ya quelques années
un et on a on a arrangé ça me le fait
qu'on va céder une histoire de garçon
quoi le truc à un moment donné quand
même temps ah ben je me suis refait ma
tête moi la cause de cet écho à
l'histoire aux l'histoire elle est très
simple c'est que laurent a voulu lancer
le défi et puis et puis franck a voulu
relever moi je les relever si tu prends
une droite en deux secondes
j'ai gagné j'ai pris en 3 bien alors je
voudrais dire moment que tu mettes très
sympathique ça me vient du coeur je te
le dire comme ça mais tout à l'heure
quand tu m'as dit bonjour c'était pas
très très gentil
non mais je mets pas d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure et là maintenant je sais pas
j'aime ouvre à toi je te trouve à tu
t'ouvres avoué oui carrément bien tant
que bien donc vous naissez dans ce
quartier défavorisé c'est le moins qu'on
puisse en dire de tunis et votre père
meurt 40 jours avant votre naissance et
avant de nous et ils avaient dit si
c'est un garçon je veux qu'il aille en
france chez mon frère
alors voilà votre mère dit à votre oncle
si tu veux mon fils il feu me donner de
l'argent
ce qui fait qu'en fait vous avez été
vendu à savoir qu'avant moi y avait
quand même des frères et soeurs et 15
nuits voilà donc apparemment
entre guillemets c'est peut-être pour
les mails et les faire manger moins
qu'elle a voulu essayer de toucher un
petit peu de sous mais moi en tant qu'
en tant qu'être humain quand j'apprends
ça je suis dégoûté quoi découvre les
verts nous avons dû lui dit comme un coq
hommes comme un show comme un animal
comme un esclave en fait il était vendu
à votre oncle c'est à dire que lui en
fait mon autre qui est devenu mon père a
voulu faire le désir de son frère qui
était mon père et puis il a tenu son
engagement dont qu'il a il a fallu usa
oui vous a recueilli à payer votre mère
et vous avez maintenant je ne sais pas
s'il a donné de l'argent s'il a ramené
des vêtements ou de la nourriture ou je
ne sais pas comment ça s'est passé mais
en tout cas je sais qu'on ne savait pas
quel prix vous avez été vendus en fait
aux dernières nouvelles je sais que j'ai
été vendus entre voilà alors vous avez
revu votre mère trois fois dans votre
vie
une fois vous avez 20 ans will tell me
fait un numéro de veuves éplorées elle
vous raconte qu'elle a été obligée de
vous ne vous abandonnez et et vous en
faites vous dit pas question d'y montrer
de l'amour quoi après ce qu'elle avait
fait pour moi c'est un être humain mais
pour moi c'est une étrangère c'est à
dire que quand je la vois je n'ai pas le
sentiment d'avoir un lien de parenté
avec cette place sentiment maternel peau
avant tout le kit a fait voilà chers que
j'ai pas voulu sauter dans les bras je
n'ai pas embrassé comme si c'était un
enfant qui a pas vu sa mère depuis les
années qui lui saute dessus
c'est une personne m'a dit bonjour je
vous dis bonjour mais j'ai pas eu le
sentiment de
d'être le père le fils de cette femme
mais en même temps c'était une chance
vous le dit d'ailleurs qu'elle vous
vendent parce que si vous n'aviez pas
été vendus en forte hausse du cac si
vous n'étiez pas venu en france à
l'époque
vous dites je serai peut-être en train
de pousser une charrette en haillons
dans une rue de tunis
c'est vrai que c'était un mal pour un
bien mais mais d'un autre côté aussi
j'ai pas j'ai pas grandi avec mes frères
et soeurs jlm a connu l'année familiales
j'ai pas connu un les anniversaires
entre familles j'ai pas connu le les
embrouilles entre frères et soeurs j'ai
pas connu tout ça c'est vrai que la vie
n'était pas très drôle si votre oncle
larbi en fait votre père adoptif il est
un petit peu contraint forcé de vous
prendre 8 il me subissez plus qu'autre
chose il n'avait pas le choix ils
étaient coincés par la promesse qu'avait
il est fait à mon père est d'ailleurs
pas de place dans la maison vous dormez
dans le salon sur le canapé un peu comme
un invité quoi c'est à dire que jusqu'à
l'âge de 15 ans effectivement on
habitait dans le 20ème du côté de la
porte de montreuil et j'avais pas de
chambres à moi je dormais dans le salon
jeu
j'attendais que quand il y avait des
invités j'attendais qu'il parte pour
pouvoir les dormir ou alors je commence
à dormir dans las dans leur chambre et
après j'allais dormir dans la salle à
manger dire que ni ni en france ni en
tunisie je me suis senti bien quelque
part vous avez 11 ans vous apprenez la
vérité photos à l'appui
je vous avoue qui s'appelle farid vous
dit en fait tes parents ne sont pas tes
parents j'espère qu'on lui déjà lui déjà
il s'est comporté comme un même pas de
mot pour le justifier parce que ça a été
une vengeance dire que le lui et sa
soeur sont venus en france
mon père kleiza les a recueillis et un
moment donné il ya un problème familial
donc ils ont été virés élus pour se
venger de sa est venu me voir moi à
l'âge de 11 ans qui à la limite n'est
pas n'est pas obligé de comprendre les
histoires d'adultes entre le marchand il
aurait mieux valu attendre un peu c'est
vrai soit ils arrivent fallu attendre un
petit peu soit ne pas le dire du tout
ouais ou soi que ce soit eux c'est à
dire mon père et ma mère qui me l'a
prennent eux-mêmes
j'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir une
vengeance vous dire que moi j'étais au
milieu d'une entre guillemets une guerre
familiale
ben c'est moi qui en a subi les
conséquences un enfant de 11 ans quand
on lui apprend qu'il va sécher le cours
d'anglais qui est en train de jouer au
flipper dans un bar du 20e de la rue des
pyrénées etc n 1 qui arrive et qui lui
dit il faut que je te parle entre hommes
dafy s'adopter je vous garantis que
c'est c'est mieux qu'une douche froide
compenser un on sait plus dans quel
parti donc dans quel côté on pas clair
oui vous dit j'avais vécu entouré de
menteur je ne pouvais donc plus me fier
à personne
là vous perdez confiance dans l'humanité
toute entière dans la famille déjà déjà
et vous péter les plombs vous disjoncter
vous commencez les fugues vous en faites
une par mois à peu près à l'époque - en
règle générale j'arrivais toujours un
petit peu me débrouiller à payer une
chambre d'hôtel avec avec un sandwich
merguez pour pouvoir on obligé de rouler
à 11 ans comme on veux tu qu'on fasse
des vols effectivement vous dit j'étais
devenue une véritable petite keira un
caïd de bac à sable
dites vous et puis à la maison basse et
pas beaucoup de tendresse un bon dj pas
eu un seul cas l'un d'eux tout mon
enfant c'est même pire que ça c'est à
dire que quand je traversais la rue avec
ma mère ou avec mon père n'y en avait
pas un qui me tenait la main ouais c'est
à dire que j'avais même pas une personne
qui me caresser les cheveux ou l'iran
en soi
adan hashi réfléchi quand on réfléchit
aux choses c'est à dire qu'il ya peu de
choses pour un enfant heureux et c'est
peu de choses ne sont pas capables
donnez donnez donc c'est à mon donné on
sait plus sur quel pied danser on n'a
plus de sens n'a plus de repère quoi
alors à 15 ans vous découvrez les filles
les cambriolages à 17 ans alors là vous
vous retrouvez dans les commandos
parachutistes au liban à beyrouth suite
à un vol à main armée vous deviez même
pas commis derrière voilà quand ça ça
n'a rien arrangé à la sortie de sa vous
entrez dans la voyoucratie vous commencé
à fréquenter des gangsters corses et
marseillais la bande de la brise de mer
après vous travaillez solo en votre
boulot c'est racketter les bars à filles
ça c'est votre spécialité tels que
comment vous faites un bar à filles vous
allez voir le mec vous lui dites si tu
veux pas voir dans merde tu me fit de
l'ubs les oies mais il ya un montage en
passons dans le milieu de la nuit a
toujours des problèmes
donc il suffit de rentrer dans le
sillage du problème et ou d'envoyer
d'aidé des histoires à savourer créer
des histoires dans un bar est ensuite
vite au mec moi je peux tu as rangé le
co voilà mais déjà les trois quarts du
temps déjà on a pas besoin d'envoyer
parce qu'ils les font tout seuls les
histoires donc exit savoir quels sont
les problèmes du mec du patron de bar
ainsi levé s'il aime la drogue chelem
les mecs si voilà vous essayez t on
essaye de lui envoyer ces points meubles
voilà on essaye de l'envoyer son petit
péché mignon dans dans le filet et puis
les trois quarts du temps et tombent
dedans et puis voilà quoi être des
timbres en terre qu'en fait en fait
en fait il faut le mettre à la faute toi
tu caches les doigts et le hebei chacun
se partagent le travail on va dire comme
ça voilà vous appeler mon moule boxer
dans le milieu au turbulent époque où le
turbulent
vous êtes même à un moment soupçonnée de
meurtre
ouais sur une fille que vous aimez bien
et en fait non non en fait c'est un flic
qui l'avait tuée ouais qu'il faisait son
service militaire qui voulait se faire
que si on s'est fait tuer les voilà il a
tué donc
cathy notre fille à l'étoile et un
chauffeur de taxi
ouais ouais et par contre j'étais le
suspect numéro un
l'arabe jeune varane et j'étais toi tu
as tué personne homos n'ont jamais jeter
d'avis quand même tu racontes tout ça
mon bouquin gérera draine tous âges et
j'ai jamais eu de sang qui a coulé sont
mes mains j'arrive bien les gants pour
ça ouais toujours pensé non mais ça n'a
l'air de rien tu te la mets sur ton club
merci patron c'est moi qui régale donc
vous raconter la prison lors huit ans en
prison ya pas de gaulois on ya pas de
français de souche commande est très
très très très peu wave mecque du 15 pas
le legs du cese pas de mec du vide quoi
encore moins de neuilly vous parlez des
maths en une phrase terrible conserver
ma temps vous dit
eux ils sont là pour la vie ah oui ils
ont signé à perpète ouais c'est clair
qu'en fait c'est vrai ils sont contrôlés
voix quand on les voit le soir les
surveillants du soir revenir avec leurs
sacs à dos et leur duvet dedans est tout
c'est un le fait de savoir que tous les
jours ils doivent rentrer dans ce dans
cet établissement c'est que quelque part
et puis voilà vous quittez le banditisme
à cause de votre fils sofiane gratte
reprise grâce qu'est ce que dit grâce
d'un public bien non c'est vrai bravo
grâce grâce à l'amour de ma vie c'est un
ce petit bonhomme il fait des câlins
voulu caresser les cheveux tu aimais des
modèles quand même jamais jamais sa tête
sur mon épaule ou mon épaule sauce ma
tête sur son épaule c'est tous les jours
depuis vous avez quand même découvert le
cinéma - papa pas avec des grands grands
rôles encore mais ouais je persiste
voilà vous avez quitté la boxe 77 combat
77 victoires
vous avez rencontré massimo gargia qui
vous a introduit dans la jet set
oui c'est une façon de parler comme il
dit ça il dit qu'il veut pas être un
vous dit
pas de gigolo en débutant dans la jet
set qui sont chez des maîtres l'aube
services web voilà c'est pas observé sid
et vous devenez un pipe all when people
entre guillemets ouest un peu people
ouais j'ai fait quelques soirées people
j'ai fait j'ai fait quelques soirées
j'ai fait quelques photos et j'ai fait
aussi la visite il ne reste plus qu'à
devenir blonde pour être considéré comme
un bon français
vous y pensez à devenir blanc pas trop
non visés d'un bad boy enfin annexes en
tous les cas ça vous énerve les stars
qui jouent les bad boys
bah oui bah oui ouais bah oui c'est ce
qui qui sont des histoires des cv avec
soi disant 1 passe et 1 au placard de
placards de machin qu'alors que même une
carla lui se met à pleurer
alors maintenant au moment où il vous
reste plus qu'à trouver une petite femme
ouais hein chercher là ont bien sûr
qu'on cherche maintenant on va pas
trouver ça tous les jours mais
effectivement j'ai envie de fonder notre
une vraie famille avec avec une femme et
d'autres enfants en fait vous regretter
d'avoir quitté karine ah bah oui ça a
été la plus grosse commune mali très
touchant quand vous racontez ça c'était
la plus grosse et d'ailleurs je me suis
excusé dans un livre et je m'en excuse
encore là effectivement j'ai fait
j'étais un [ __ ] vis-à-vis d'elle
karine vous étiez bien avec elle un jour
elle va se reposer chez sa mère parce
qu'on a une fille qui vous appelle vous
y allez vous la sauter on est en cloque
et elle vous dit si tu veux que je garde
le gosse il faut m'épouser devrait est
en fait elle avait 7 ans de
de plus que vous et vous l'avez vous
avez épousé sa pas duré longtemps après
ah non ça c'est clair quand le momen et
vous étiez déjà séparé ouais et karine
herry ou là bas une époque qu'elle
travaille pour une grande marque de
bijoux du côté de la place vendôme voilà
et il va les plans de la boutique
et puis une fois que une fois que le
petit a été nez gelé revue et elle m'a
dit que c'était pas beau c'est une qu'on
puisse se remettre ensemble parce que
justement par rapport au petit elle le
verra le verra voilà dire qu'elle était
il faut dire que karine était enceinte
de moi l'a fait une fausse couche donc
donc si vous voulez après il ya eu un
décalage pour me sers enfants que vous
avez l'ehpad karine mais c'est la chine
voilà mais bon je suis content d'avoir
mon fils aussi ouais on est content de
voir comme ça en tous les cas c'est
gentil merci
les yeux
michel lafon